name me five living directors that could
teach you something about directing
Steven Spielberg because he's just such
a perfect filmmaker as far as like you
know when he comes up like The Taking of
Shanghai sequence for instance in in
Empire of the Sun and I I talked to him
about Private Ryan he goes oh we're
going to create the greatest like taking
of Omaha Beach ever and I have no doubt
he will he's just the master of the film
he's making now exactly this one coming
out you know and I'm sure he's going to
do the greatest taking of Omaha Beach
ever captured in cinema that kind of
filmmaking language I think I've got it
too but in a different way but I could
learn something from him Spielberg would
be one I could learn from Scorsese but
how I could learn from Scorsese is not
like how he does anything you know what
I mean because how he does it is how he
does it and how I do it is how I do it
Scorsese is so much film and love of
film I might be a better director if I
just had dinner at his house every week
and we just talked all right not about
filmmaking per se and I wouldn't doubt
that he didn't feel that way about
Fellini too